the jurgen experience now you've
been you use a lot of local ingredients
but you've also been doing this thing
where you
uh take people hunting and show them how
to butcher an animal and show them how
to cook an animal
right when did you start doing that that
was in 2008 so
shortly after we started doing
classes on butchery of domestic pork
which was kind of my wheelhouse i'd
learned that in restaurant
work i've been a prep cook in a butcher
and restaurant
and being new to hunting at that point
i had just started hunting a couple
years prior and was really excited about
it
and saw the opportunity to really kind
of tie the two
together you know i i knew how to
butcher before i knew how to hunt
and so that i had a little bit of an
advantage on the back end of it but
still
have and still do have to this day a lot
to learn about the front end of it
and i wanted to be able to share that
with people because i
i think that hunting is a very key way
to show people the importance of food
because if you can feel
sad about taking the life of a deer or a
pig or a squirrel
then you can also understand what a case
of
carrots that is you know rotting at a
grocery store because they haven't been
sold or they're not they don't look good
enough to sell anymore
that's also sad to me and and you know a
lot of work went into that
and and so much it's immeasurable
and so being able to tie food uh with
the with the source
like that with hunting or fishing or
whatever i think was really important so
we started doing classes
where we were taking people out and we
would it's guided hunts
and then you learn how to butcher cook
and then you eat game throughout the
weekend too and we still do that to this
day
and when you do this how many times a
year do you do this uh
you know well um you know in season it's
it's texas so it's hot our season
typically runs
if we if we have a couple dove hunts or
something in there from mid-september
till uh maybe april
um so just basically the cooler and cool
and cold months of of the year so about
six seven months
and when you do it would you do it on
weekends like when when do you uh
yeah they're they're they're typically
weekend classes um we used to do a lot
of private events and now i've just gone
to where we work with one ranch
um we do a friday through sunday class
and
um in all honesty though our our whole
season this year
has fairly much been booked up by uh
people that came to previous classes
they come back we have a pretty high
return rate on those
we're about to release our schedule of
those but there's going to be very
very little seats available to those
they fill up we do eight classes a year
for four people
you kind of would if you're hunting too
you're you're going to need
small groups right you really can't yeah
it's and it's got to be very intimate
you know we want everybody to see
everything and put their hands on it so
it's it's really necessary we have a
team of guides so everybody if you've
never been hunting before you have a
guide we walk you through the whole
um the whole series of events like from
siding in the gun to um you know it's
this constant barrage of like learning
this like this is how you put your heel
down you know
this is the way the wind is blowing this
is the way we're gonna walk to do this
you know this is uh what time of day we
expect
deer to move when we expect hogs to move
why we're sitting right here
all kind of you know we're like
constantly feeding information and then
once that animal is taken we're feeding
you know more information about
your skin that's how you gut this is how
you use the liver this is called fat
this is a shank this is best for grind
this is best for slow cooking things
like that
and then we teach them how to how to
butcher it break it down
and then we really want them to be able
to do it on their own and
the whole time we feed them game to kind
of really keep it in context
because a lot of times people have been
told oh you know that you can't eat
that you know you can't you know do your
liver is no good or
or venison tastes gamey to me or i'm not
going to touch the hog topic yet but um
you know people are
very opinionated about
hogs and uh we try to just kind of
dispel those myths and
empower and educate people and to be
able to do it on their own and whether
or not they go and do it in the future
i don't really know but i do think that
it gives them some very good
connectivity i mean i know people that
it came on a trip
12 years ago that still talk about it to
me and
i think it was important and i mean
that's very that's really important to
me and very meaningful
that it's it's a it's a formative
experience even if they never do
it again you know but it teaches them to
really value a resource that time they
killed a deer because it's really hard
to like for me
uh once you've killed that deer if you
open up a bag
of beef or something i i can't but help
but think like
all those animals in a field
you know they all had lives they all had
deaths everything you know it's like
and i think it teaches you to appreciate
resources and once you start to
appreciate
that resource uh maybe you'll start to
appreciate
all resources you know right you'll
appreciate the vegetables everything
else
you might appreciate where your clothes
are made right right or
do we need a leaf blower you know things
like that
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience